to be able in this day and age to say
i get to portray a black female
superhero
and be that vision that
image that i wish prayed i would have
seen as a young girl it's
really incredibly um an honor and
a blessing and i'm just really excited
for the opportunity and
i'm having a lot of fun they're really
fun over here
wanda what's up who are you
i don't know this is really cool because
you get to wear the badge of like the
first
mcu spin-off out of the gate what is
that like getting to kind of wear that
badge of honor
i mean we didn't know we were going to
be the first you know a lot of this
happened over the past year and it's
like oh we're up
okay you know we're ready we are ready
it's been so cool just the way that
the fact that the mcu is coming to
television
yeah and this is a show that actually
pays homage to
american television by um going through
the decades
and each episode sort of being a tribute
and an homage to
that decade i'm looking forward to the
fashions of all the decades of all the
like the television shows so we first
saw that very first episode we
saw kind of the classic tv throwback to
classic tv the 50s
were you kind of were you partial to any
era or
was there one that you really gravitated
towards i will say that
the 50s episode i got to actually watch
some of it while they you know the mtu
did their first time with
taping with a live audience and so i got
to watch some of it so
not only did you have the fashions but
just watching the style in which
they filmed it with the live audience
and it just felt like a theater piece
and
um watching paul and lizzy and katherine
just
really work it you know really just so
flawlessly and beautifully um that was
exciting
i think as much of a career woman as
like you know
um involved woman as i believe i am i
think that i would be a really dope 50s
health
housewife because i love to cook i love
to entertain
i like like all of those things i'm like
i think i could do that what about you
how do you think you would fare as a 50s
house
terrible it's too much too much work i'm
not doing all of this
in my mind i'm that person that
gal that wife that woman but
in reality i can't play myself i'm not
it's too much work i don't want to wear
the
girdle i don't want to do nails i don't
want to do any of that
i hear it no it's funny because my
mother always says to me you hate
combing your hair you hate putting on
makeup why the hell are you on
television
usually you can have someone help you
with that you're like i just sit there
and they give you everything but in
these covey days i have you know that's
been like oh
i gotta pull this together myself
exactly it's a lot it's too much
yeah for real in the first episode we
also see wanda
you know mistake this important work
dinner for an anniversary dinner and she
shows up in this kind of negligee or
whatever
have you ever had that moment where you
show up to an event and you're just
woefully either underdressed overdressed
and you
just totally miss the mark absolutely
i think my thing is i think i come
overdressed sometimes
i have to learn the um the casual
sleigh a little better like that like
over a little over
casual but not like girl you're not
going to the oscars or enemies you know
that version so i'm i'm working on that
but i think i've
come over dressed a lot but now after
this quarantine
i might come underdressed more
everybody's got on their
silk pajamas with the high heels that's
what's gonna be the norm
the blend of you and i would be perfect
because i'm always
so underdressed really
worse i'm only overdressed because other
people dress me
and i'm like yeah i like that and i
picked the thing but if i had to do it
myself
underdressed underneath exactly okay so
we know that you are going to be
in captain marvel too yay thumbs up to
that
what does that mean to you to be able to
number one embody this role
and be such a part of bringing like such
a diverse
superhero to the mcu yes well
well so monica rambo in the comics she
was
um actually the first captain marvel
second to marvel himself but she was
named marvel
by the people so she was kind of the
first in that way
um and so to be able
in this day and age to say i get to
portray a black
female superhero and be
that vision that image that i
wish prayed i would have seen as a young
girl it's
really incredibly um an honor and
a blessing and i'm just really excited
for the opportunity and
i'm having a lot of fun they're really
fun over here
okay so you know we look at some
instagrams and it looks like that you
and bree
have the same kind of workout setup
[Laughter]
but freeze guy going over there but i'm
sure she is kicking ass i'm over here
trying i am trying you know
in my mind last year when it was
announced i was going to be
in the gym going hard but because of the
quarantine i've had to readjust
and i started like building a little
gym in a garage and but a lot of it has
had like where i thought oh i'll be able
to do heavy weights
you have to do body weight and figuring
out different things so it's not
what i imagined but it it's gonna be
amazing whatever it
is and i'm trying y'all i'm trying do
you get the marvel
update to your home gym do they say okay
we're gonna send this batter the third
no nobody said anything i got my little
80s shake weights no i'm joking
no one said anything i think they kind
of leave it to what do you want to do
then you do that um maybe if i asked
they would but
i'm just over here doing my kickbacks
and my body weight i'm just trying to
get it just trying to keep
tiana do you have um do you have
especially during this time because i
think
a lot of us have taken 2020 and now this
crazy time into 2021 to
um to reflect do you still have like the
sit back and pinch me moments like damn
look at my life this is pretty dope
absolutely i
i the i am so incredibly blessed and i
don't take it for granted i think it's i
think i will be honest sometimes you
lose
i have lost sight of that during this
year um because again like i said it
just looks so different than what i
imagined
and so having to come back to myself and
remind myself like no
this is um this does mean
something it just looks different and
i'm having to reconcile
that part uh in my head because again
you have these expectations these
anticipations that you set for yourself
and a lot of times in life if it doesn't
look exactly like that you
you you have to readjust yeah
and i think we're all doing that